Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In the temple square, the drummers struck up a pounding rhythm. The dancers joined hands once again. 400 of the bravest and strongest young men in the city. The crowds began to chant and clap. Hundreds and hundreds of men, women and children, their faces shining with religious excitement.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在神庙广场上，鼓手们敲响了沉重的节奏。舞者们再次手牵手，那是城里400名最勇敢、最强壮的年轻人。人群开始吟唱和鼓掌。成百上千的男人、女人和孩子，脸上闪烁着宗教狂热的光芒。
None of them, of course, had brought weapons. Round and round the dancers whirled faster and faster. The drummers hammered louder and louder. The sun beat down hotter and hotter. In their excitement, nobody noticed the Spaniards closing the gates leading out of the temple precinct and taking up their positions around the edge of the square. Round and round went the dancers in wave after wave of joy and passion, louder and louder, hotter and hotter, faster and faster. Alvarado drew his sword. His eyes were burning. For just a fraction of a second, the drummers faltered. Meran! he screamed. Let them die! So began the carnage. Thrilling prose there, Dominic, from a top historian of
当然，他们都没有携带武器。舞者们转啊转，越转越快。鼓手们敲啊敲，越敲越响。太阳炙烤着大地，越来越热。在狂热中，没有人注意到西班牙人关上了通往神庙区域的大门，并在广场边缘占据了位置。舞者们在一波又一波的欢乐与激情中旋转，声音越来越响，天气越来越热，速度越来越快。阿尔瓦拉多拔出了剑。他的眼睛在燃烧。在那一瞬间，鼓手们迟疑了。梅兰！他尖叫道。让他们死吧！屠杀就这样开始了。多米尼克，这段文字真是扣人心弦，出自一位顶尖历史学家之手，
the fall of the Aztecs, namely yourself, your latest volume in your Adventures of Time series. And listeners who have made it this far with us will know that we are now embarking on something unprecedented in The Rest is History, which is our first part five in a series. So over the course of this podcast, we did The French Revolution in 50 minutes, and we've been slowly expanding. So then we did two, then we've done four episode series, and now we're embarking on an eight part series. And we've had a week, haven't we, where we did the first part of this incredible story, and now we're into our second week. So Dominic, could you just give us a recap? Yes. For people who may have completely forgotten what's going on.
也就是你自己，关于阿兹特克帝国覆灭的最新著作，也是你《时间冒险》系列中的最新一卷。听众们如果跟我们走到这一步，就会知道我们现在正在开启《历史的余味》中前所未有的尝试，也就是我们系列节目中的第一个第五部分。在这一系列播客中，我们先是用了50分钟讲了法国大革命，然后慢慢扩展。我们做过两集，做过四集系列，现在我们正在开启一个八集系列。我们已经度过了一周，不是吗？我们讲了这个不可思议故事的第一部分，现在进入了第二周。所以多米尼克，你能给我们做一个回顾吗？好的。为了那些可能已经完全忘记发生了什么的人。
Of course. I find this hard to believe, of course, but... Where we are. So that scene that you were just describing is in the center of Tenochtitlan, now Mexico City, in 1520. And that scene is to come in today's podcast. But last week, we started with Hernan Cortes, born in around 1485 in Medellin in Spain, how Cortes traveled to seek his fortune in the Caribbean, first on the island of Hispaniola and then on Cuba, how he was given the job of leading a sort of scouting expedition up the coast of what we know as Mexico. But what the Spanish, and particularly Cortes' boss, the governor of Cuba, a guy called Diego Velazquez, what they thought could be a continent, could be a very large island, they didn't know, but they knew
当然。我很难相信会有人忘记，但……我们讲到哪里了。你刚才描述的那个场景发生在1520年的特诺奇蒂特兰中心，也就是现在的墨西哥城。那个场景将在今天的播客中出现。但上周，我们从埃尔南·科尔特斯开始讲起，他大约于1485年出生在西班牙的麦德林，讲述了科尔特斯如何前往加勒比海寻求财富，先是在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛，然后是古巴，以及他如何被委派领导一支侦察探险队，沿着我们现在所知的墨西哥海岸航行。但西班牙人，特别是科尔特斯的上司、古巴总督迭戈·贝拉斯克斯，认为那可能是一块大陆，也可能是一个非常大的岛屿，他们不知道，但他们知道
it probably had gold. Cortes went up the coast. He disobeyed his orders. He had been specifically told not to try and conquer that land, but he turned in land in the company of a slave girl that he had acquired called Malinche, who was translating for him, and some people now believe was partly calling the shots in what happened. He went in land, he made a deal with a city-state called Tlaxcala, the sworn enemies of the Mexica, the great power brokers of the Mexican world, the Mesoamerican world, in the city of Tenochtitlan in the center of Lake Texcoco. Cortes arrived in the capital, spent a few months with Montezuma, the emperor.
那里可能有黄金。科尔特斯沿着海岸航行。他违抗了命令。他曾被明确告知不要试图征服那片土地，但他带着一个他得到的奴隶女孩马林切转向了内陆，她为他翻译，现在有些人认为她在后来发生的事情中也起到了一定的主导作用。他进入内陆，与一个叫特拉斯卡拉的城邦达成了协议，那是墨西加人的死敌，而墨西加人是墨西哥世界、中美洲世界在特斯科科湖中心的特诺奇蒂特兰城中的大权在握者。科尔特斯抵达了首都，与皇帝蒙特祖马共处了几个月。
Then he heard that more Spaniards had arrived on the coast, probably hunting for him because he disobeyed his orders. So as we discussed last time, it's probably at that moment, Tom, that he arrested Montezuma, that Montezuma became the Spaniards' hostage. In the meantime, Cortes divided his forces. He took 80 men himself, and he and Malinche left for the coast, leaving the remaining 120 or so men in the Aztec capital, Tenochtitlan, under the command of his ally, Pedro de Alvarado. And Tom, it seems extraordinary that I've just done that in about 90 seconds. I know. That's mistaken as well.
然后他听说更多的西班牙人抵达了海岸，可能是因为他违抗命令而专门来抓他的。所以正如我们上次讨论的那样，汤姆，可能就在那一刻，他逮捕了蒙特祖马，蒙特祖马成了西班牙人的人质。与此同时，科尔特斯分兵了。他自己带了80人，和马林切一起离开了海岸，留下剩下的120人左右在阿兹特克首都特诺奇蒂特兰，由他的盟友佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多指挥。汤姆，我刚才在90秒内讲完这一切，真是太不可思议了。我知道。那也是个误解。
About kind of four hours. Yes. However, as you rightly said last time, although many aspects of Cortes' character are obscure and we will never know them, it is quite clear that he is a man who continually takes gambles. He's a risk taker, and this is a colossal risk to divide your forces and to head back to the coast. And also to take prisoner, the leader of the greatest empire in America. Yes. When you're surrounded by millions of people who are loyal to him.
大约四个小时。是的。然而，正如你上次正确指出的那样，虽然科尔特斯性格的许多方面都很模糊，我们永远无法完全了解，但很明显，他是一个不断冒险的人。他是一个冒险家，分兵并返回海岸是一个巨大的风险。而且还囚禁了美洲最伟大帝国的领袖。是的。当你被数百万忠于他的人包围时。
Yeah. And of course, I mean, most people who listen to this podcast might not know the details of the story, but they will have a strong suspicion that this gamble is going to work. But Cortes can't know that as he is marching back east. No. So the sense of jeopardy is enormous. Yeah. And the almost lunatic quality of his courage.
是的。当然，我的意思是，大多数听这个播客的人可能不知道故事的细节，但他们会强烈怀疑这次冒险会成功。但科尔特斯在向东行军时并不知道这一点。不。所以那种危机感是巨大的。是的。还有他那近乎疯狂的勇气。
Yes. So the interesting thing with Hernan Cortes, as I said, so much of his personality is lost to us. And the most brilliant recent book, which we talked about last time by a historian called Matthew Restle. Matthew Restle, like most modern historians, absolutely despises Cortes. And Cortes' reputation in Mexico, if you see paintings and murals and things, he's shown as an utter villain, a man of the absolutely worst kind. And Matthew Restle sees him as a mediocrity, doesn't he? A total mediocrity.
是的。所以关于埃尔南·科尔特斯有趣的一点是，正如我所说，他的大部分个性对我们来说已经失传了。我们上次谈到的由历史学家马修·雷斯特尔所著的最近最精彩的书。马修·雷斯特尔像大多数现代历史学家一样，绝对鄙视科尔特斯。科尔特斯在墨西哥的声誉，如果你看到绘画和壁画之类的东西，他被描绘成一个彻头彻尾的恶棍，一个最坏的人。而马修·雷斯特尔认为他是一个平庸之辈，不是吗？一个彻底的平庸之辈。
That's the really fascinating thing is that I've read accounts in which Cortez is the hero, and I've read accounts in which he is a satanic, malign figure, equivalent of Milton Satan. Restle's is the first that I've read in which he is neither a hero nor a supervillain, but faintly dull, a kind of flashman who is in the right place at the right time and able to claim credit for things that he doesn't actually do. Well, Matthew Restle wants you to believe that he's basically the assistant manager of a leisure centre. Yes. That he's a man with no qualities of any kind. Well, his only quality is an ability to manipulate and lie. Yeah.
最令人着迷的是，我读过将科尔特斯描述为英雄的记载，也读过将他描述为撒旦般邪恶人物的记载，相当于弥尔顿笔下的撒旦。雷斯特尔的书是我读过的第一本既不把他写成英雄也不写成超级恶棍，而是写得平淡无奇，像是一个在正确的时间出现在正确地点，并能为自己实际上没做过的事情邀功的“闪光人”。好吧，马修·雷斯特尔想让你相信他基本上就是一个休闲中心的助理经理。是的。他是一个没有任何品质的人。好吧，他唯一的品质就是操纵和撒谎的能力。是的。
And I think at the end of this series, we should look again at Cortez's character, see what conclusions we've come to about what was motivating him, what qualities or vices he may embody, and why historians have cast him in the way that they do. So I think that'd be a very interesting theme. But for now, I think that we should hold to, I think, the sense that both of us have that he's certainly not a mediocrity. He's a man capable of extraordinary gambles and extraordinary feats of courage. I mean, whatever else you think of him. Yeah. You use the word courage,
我认为在这个系列结束时，我们应该重新审视科尔特斯的性格，看看我们对他动机的结论，他可能体现了什么品质或恶习，以及为什么历史学家会这样评价他。所以我认为这将是一个非常有趣的主题。但现在，我认为我们应该坚持我们两人的看法，即他绝对不是一个平庸之辈。他是一个有能力进行非凡冒险和展现非凡勇气的人。我的意思是，无论你对他有什么其他看法。是的。你用了“勇气”这个词，
and that's what made me think of it, actually, because I think you're right. It does take extraordinary courage to do this. I mean, he's in for a penny, in for a pound, and to some extent, I suppose you could argue he has to do it. But he's marching to the coast. He doesn't really know who is waiting for him. Now, the man who is waiting for him on the coast, we met back in the very first episode, and I said to people then, don't forget this bloke. So here he is again, and he is a guy called Panfilo de Narbaez. It's probably about this point, Tom, that I should remind our listeners that we are a very inclusive podcast. The rest is history.
这确实让我想到了这一点，因为我认为你是对的。做这件事确实需要非凡的勇气。我的意思是，他已经孤注一掷了，在某种程度上，我想你可以说他不得不这样做。但他正在向海岸行军。他真的不知道谁在等着他。现在，在海岸等着他的那个人，我们在第一集就见过，我当时对大家说，别忘了这个家伙。所以他又出现了，他是一个叫潘菲洛·德·纳尔瓦埃斯的人。汤姆，大概就在这一点上，我应该提醒我们的听众，我们是一个非常包容的播客。《历史的余味》。
So we will be doing a range of different pronunciations of the Spanish names. We're not being inconsistent, are we, Tom? No, we're not. We're celebrating diversity. We are. So sometimes we'll pronounce them in a Castilian way. Sometimes, to please our American listeners, we'll be pronouncing them in the way that one would if one were a patron of a Hooters in North Dakota. And sometimes, because we are also a very patriotic podcast, in a defiantly English way.
所以我们将对西班牙名字进行各种不同的发音。我们并不是前后不一，对吧，汤姆？不，我们不是。我们在庆祝多样性。我们是。所以有时我们会用卡斯蒂利亚语发音。有时，为了取悦我们的美国听众，我们会用北达科他州一家猫头鹰餐厅（Hooters）常客的方式发音。有时，因为我们也是一个非常爱国的播客，我们会用一种挑衅性的英式发音。
Exactly. That's a deliberate choice, isn't it? It's an important choice born of inclusivity. And sometimes with just a hint of naruata. Right. So, Panfilo de Narbaez is on the coast. Now, who is he? He is this gigantic, red-bearded Castilian veteran who had waded through blood on Jamaica and on Cuba, who was well known for his extraordinary ferocity to the Tainos villages on those islands. And he is working for the governor of Cuba, Diego Velazquez. Who's fat and jolly, isn't he? Well, fat and jolly-ish by Spanish. I mean, he still kills a lot of people. Theo, our producer, is asking the key question.
没错。这是一个故意的选择，不是吗？这是一个源于包容性的重要选择。有时还带有一点纳瓦特尔语的味道。好吧。所以，潘菲洛·德·纳尔瓦埃斯在海岸上。那么，他是谁？他是一个巨大的、红胡子的卡斯蒂利亚老兵，曾在牙买加和古巴的血泊中跋涉，他以对那些岛屿上的泰诺村庄的极端残暴而闻名。他为古巴总督迭戈·贝拉斯克斯工作。他是个又胖又快乐的人，不是吗？嗯，按西班牙人的标准来说，又胖又快乐。我的意思是，他仍然杀了很多很多人。我们的制片人西奥问了一个关键问题。
He says, why are all the Spaniards apparently ginger? I don't know why that is, because people say Hernan Cortes is slightly red-bearded as well. I think it must be just in contrast to the Mesoamericans. They're from the Northwest, aren't they? I think so. The Celtic. The Celtiberians. The Celtiberian heritage.
他说，为什么所有的西班牙人看起来都是姜黄色的头发？我不知道为什么，因为人们说埃尔南·科尔特斯的胡子也是微红色的。我想这一定只是与中美洲人形成对比。他们来自西北部，对吧？我想是这样。凯尔特人。凯尔特伊比利亚人。凯尔特伊比利亚人的血统。
Well, Cortes isn't from the Northwest. Cortes is from Extremadura. Yeah, but that's kind of just down from Galicia. For a hundred miles. Yeah, well, passing Tinker or something at some point. Just imagine the Spanish as being red bearded. This guy is like, there's a big red bearded guy, isn't there, in Game of Thrones. He's one of the wildlings.
嗯，科尔特斯不是来自西北部。科尔特斯来自埃斯特雷马杜拉。是的，但那离加利西亚只有一百英里。是的，好吧，在某个时候经过廷克（Tinker）之类的。想象一下西班牙人都是红胡子。这家伙就像，《权力的游戏》里有个大红胡子家伙，对吧？他是野人之一。
Ha ha ha ha ha ha. Is that what he is? Yeah. Now, Earth is like him. There is much killing to be had here. Yes. He's like a Viking. That's exactly... I know the guy you mean.
哈哈哈哈。他是那样的吗？是的。现在，地球就像他一样。这里有很多杀戮。是的。他就像一个维京人。那正是……我知道你指的是谁。
Yeah. He's a sort of Icelandic or Norwegian actor. Unleash the dogs of hell. Kind of Brian Blessed. Right. But psychotic. That is absolutely... Tom, that becomes...
是的。他是一个冰岛或挪威演员。释放地狱之犬。有点像布莱恩·布莱斯德（Brian Blessed）。对。但有精神病。那绝对是……汤姆，那变成了……
I know you just want to do the whole thing in the voice of Brian Blessed, but you see, I want to do the whole thing in the voice of Manuel from Fawlty Towers. Anyway, that's by the by. So what had happened is this. You may remember, if you were listening closely last week, that when Cortes turned in land,
我知道你只是想用布莱恩·布莱斯德的声音做整件事，但你看，我想用《弗尔蒂旅馆》（Fawlty Towers）里曼努埃尔的声音做整件事。总之，那是题外话。所以发生的事情是这样的。如果你上周听得很仔细，你可能还记得，当科尔特斯转向内陆时，
he sent some of the gold back to Spain. He sent it under a guy called Montero and told him, take it back to the King of Spain. This will butter him up and this will basically buy me credit for when everyone says I've disobeyed my orders. But what Cortes did not know was that Montero would stop on the way on Cuba, that the gold would be spotted, which is exactly what happened, and that this would be reported to Velázquez in the capital, Santiago. So Cortes is off messing around with indigenous peoples in Mexico. Meanwhile, on Cuba, Velazquez is going absolutely
他把一些黄金送回了西班牙。他派了一个叫蒙特罗的人，告诉他，把它带给西班牙国王。这会讨好他，基本上会为我买到信用，当每个人都说我违抗命令时。但科尔特斯不知道的是，蒙特罗会在去古巴的路上停下来，黄金会被发现，这正是发生的事情，而且这会被报告给首都圣地亚哥的贝拉斯克斯。所以科尔特斯在墨西哥和土著人民胡闹。与此同时，在古巴，贝拉斯克斯绝对
mental with rage. Again, he can't go himself because of the massive smallpox epidemic on Cuba, which is killing all, as he sees it, all his workforce, the indigenous people. So he contracts Narbaez and says, go to Mexico, deal with Cortes, bring him back dead or alive. He can't be off stealing what I see as my own lands, this frontier that I want to explore myself. So Narbaez has pitched up with a thousand men. Now, luckily for Cortes, he had left some people on the coast under the command of his friend, Gonzalo de Sandoval. And they are loyal to him. They're still loyal. They defend Veracruz. They hold out against Narbaez. So Narbaez falls back to the nearby Tottenham town of Zempoala, and he is based there.
气疯了。同样，他不能亲自去，因为古巴爆发了大规模的天花疫情，在他看来，这正在杀死他所有的劳动力，即土著人民。所以他雇佣了纳尔瓦埃斯，说，去墨西哥，处理掉科尔特斯，把他带回来，死活不论。他不能去偷我认为是我自己的土地，这个我想亲自探索的边疆。所以纳尔瓦埃斯带了一千人来了。现在，幸运的是，科尔特斯在海岸留下了一些人，由他的朋友贡萨洛·德·桑多瓦尔指挥。他们对他很忠诚。他们仍然忠诚。他们保卫韦拉克鲁斯。他们抵御纳尔瓦埃斯。所以纳尔瓦埃斯撤退到附近的托托纳克城镇森波阿拉，并驻扎在那里。
So he's there with his thousand men. Cortes, Malinche, and their 80 men are kind of trudging across the landscape. By the way, we are massively simplifying this story. I mean, if you read Bernal Diaz or something. Because it's a long way. Yeah. It's a long way. So we're actually, you think this is a long series. We're skipping loads of interactions with towns, negotiations with chiefs.
所以他带着一千人和他在一起。科尔特斯、马林切和他们的80人正艰难地穿过这片土地。顺便说一句，我们极大地简化了这个故事。我的意思是，如果你读伯纳尔·迪亚斯之类的书。因为路很长。是的。路很长。所以我们实际上，你以为这是一个很长的系列。我们跳过了与城镇的大量互动，与酋长的谈判。
Terrifying wildlife. Exchanges of feathers, all this kind of, we're skipping all that, aren't we, Tom? We are. Because we're very much a highlights... Highlights package. I was going to say we're the match of the day of History Podcast, but actually we're... I don't know if it's that comparison we should... Yeah, I think that's legitimate.
可怕的野生动物。羽毛的交换，所有这些，我们都跳过了，对吧，汤姆？我们是。因为我们非常像一个集锦……集锦包。我本来想说我们是历史播客中的《当日比赛》（Match of the Day），但实际上我们是……我不知道这个比较是否合适……是的，我认为这是合理的。
Maybe it is. I mean, it's presented by one of the owners of Goldhanger, so I think that's very much on brand. It is. Yeah. Presented by a great man, of course. Not that we'd be biased at all. Right.
也许是吧。我的意思是，它是由Goldhanger的老板之一主持的，所以我认为这非常符合品牌形象。是的。当然是由一位伟人主持的。并不是说我们会有偏见。对。
So Cortez is going to the coast. It's now raining. It's the rainy season. So he and his men are trudging through. Do you think there are leeches? I think there are undoubtedly leeches, mosquitoes. Great predatory sucking leeches. You name it.
所以科尔特斯要去海岸。现在下雨了。这是雨季。所以他和他的手下正艰难地跋涉。你认为有水蛭吗？我想毫无疑问有水蛭、蚊子。巨大的掠食性吸血水蛭。你能想到的都有。
They're probably in terrible health. And this again is a sign to me that he's not a mediocrity, actually, that he doesn't lose the support of his men. They must be absolutely terrified against massive odds, but we're told that he's constantly quite cheerful and upbeat and he's inspiring them and stuff. He's also clever because he is exchanging messages with Narbayeth's camp and he is sending messengers with secret letters for some of Narbayath's lieutenants and little gifts of gold and jewels from Tenochtitlan. And Cortes is saying, look at all this. Because Dominic, I mean, just to recap something we said at some point last week,
他们的健康状况可能很糟糕。这再次向我表明，他实际上不是一个平庸之辈，他没有失去手下的支持。面对巨大的困难，他们一定非常害怕，但我们被告知他总是很开朗、乐观，他在激励他们等等。他也很聪明，因为他正在与纳尔瓦埃斯的营地交换信息，他正在派遣信使带着给纳尔瓦埃斯的一些副官的秘密信件，以及来自特诺奇蒂特兰的黄金和珠宝小礼物。科尔特斯说，看看这些。因为多米尼克，我的意思是，只是回顾一下我们上周某个时候说的，
I can't remember when exactly, but that this is not an army, is it? These are a consortia of often family-based groups of men who therefore are very subornable, bribe-able even one might say. Yeah. Think of the Sopranos. Exactly. Yes. I mean, these are gangs is one way of thinking about it. I mean, it's not quite fair, but it's probably more accurate than an army. So at the end of May anyway, he's met up with Gonzalo de Sandoval, who was with the other men from the coast, his own men. They've linked up and they're outside Sempoala, where Narbaez is based. Now, Narbaez is very complacent because he has so many men. They're all sleeping up on the temples, up in the pyramids in Sempoala. I mean, this entire story is a gift to some Netflix producer. I will, however, say
我不记得具体是什么时候了，但这根本不是一支军队，对吧？这是一群通常以家庭为基础的男人组成的联合体，因此非常容易被收买，甚至可以说容易被贿赂。是的。想想《黑道家族》（The Sopranos）。没错。是的。我的意思是，把这看作帮派是一种方式。我的意思是，这不太公平，但可能比军队更准确。所以无论如何，在五月底，他与贡萨洛·德·桑多瓦尔会合了，他与海岸上的其他人，他自己的人在一起。他们已经联系上了，就在纳尔瓦埃斯驻扎的森波阿拉外面。现在，纳尔瓦埃斯非常自满，因为他有很多人。他们都睡在神庙上，睡在森波阿拉的金字塔里。我的意思是，整个故事对Netflix制片人来说是一份礼物。不过，我会说
that if you do produce this, Tom and I will expect considerable involvement and royalties. They don't believe for a minute that Cortez is going to attack them. Cortez assembles his men in the forests outside the town. And in true Hollywood spirit, Tom, he reminds them of a line from the Song of Roland, Chanson de Roland, which is one of the most loved of all chivalric romances. Where is one of the most loved of all kind of chivalric romances. Where Roland is defending the past against overwhelming odds, isn't he? Against the Moors. It is, exactly. And they would all know this story. And Cortez says to them, remember, it is better to die for a good cause than to live with dishonor. That's so true.
如果你真的制作这个，汤姆和我将期待相当大的参与和版税。他们一点也不相信科尔特斯会攻击他们。科尔特斯在城外的森林里集合了他的手下。汤姆，本着真正的好莱坞精神，他提醒他们《罗兰之歌》（Chanson de Roland）中的一句台词，这是所有骑士传奇中最受喜爱的作品之一。罗兰在压倒性的困难面前保卫关隘，不是吗？对抗摩尔人。正是如此。他们都知道这个故事。科尔特斯对他们说，记住，为正义的事业而死比带着耻辱活着要好。这太真实了。
But at the same time, Tom, the funny thing is, it's not really that good a cause. No, of course not. It's a terrible cause. Their cause is basically making money. Yes. But it's not really that good a cause no of course not it's a terrible cause their cause is basically making money yes but it's still true yes and then they strike and they strike in the dead of night when narvaez's men are all asleep but also of course when the darkness means that narvaez's advantage of numbers is much reduced and they're shouting long live the king obviously claiming that they are the loyalists here for for Cortes and the Holy Spirit, they supposedly- Because again, just to reiterate, because this is very important, the whole point of saying why Moxizuma has supposedly surrendered
但与此同时，汤姆，有趣的是，这并不是什么正义的事业。不，当然不是。这是一个糟糕的事业。他们的事业基本上就是赚钱。是的。但它仍然是真的，是的，然后他们发动了攻击，他们在深夜发动攻击，当时纳尔瓦埃斯的人都在睡觉，但也当然，黑暗意味着纳尔瓦埃斯的人数优势大大降低了，他们在大喊“国王万岁”，显然声称他们是这里的保皇党，为了科尔特斯和圣灵，他们据称——因为再次重申，因为这非常重要，说蒙特祖马据称已经投降的全部意义在于
the Aztec empire to the Spanish king is that this is key in allowing Cortes to present himself and his men as defenders of legitimacy and legality, rather than being a bunch of gangsters. Exactly. Exactly. And everything goes perfectly for Cortez. So some of Narbaez's men surrender straight away. They've probably been suborned beforehand.
将阿兹特克帝国交给西班牙国王，这是科尔特斯能够将自己和他的手下表现为合法性和法律的捍卫者，而不是一群歹徒的关键。没错。没错。一切对科尔特斯来说都很完美。所以纳尔瓦埃斯的一些手下直接投降了。他们可能事先就被收买了。
Some of them are just overpowered. They're shocked. They've been asleep. It's dark. Narbaez himself, this massive Game of Thrones-like character, he fights on in very Game of Thrones style. He's cornered at the top of the pyramid by some pikemen, and they are sort of jabbing at him with their pikes, and they manage to gouge out his eye, Tom,
他们中的一些人只是被制服了。他们很震惊。他们一直在睡觉。天很黑。纳尔瓦埃斯本人，这个巨大的《权力的游戏》式的人物，他以非常《权力的游戏》的风格继续战斗。他在金字塔顶端被一些长矛兵逼到了角落，他们用长矛刺他，汤姆，他们设法挖出了他的眼睛，
at which point he shouts, in very Shakespearean fashion, he claims that he shouted, Holy Mary, protect me, they have torn out my eye. Holy Mary, protect me, they've torn out my eye. Tom, did we need that that yeah clearly you think people did but i don't i felt that there was a lack of a lack of pizzazz in your impersonation of him that i like to think i've provided well okay so all right so cortez wins for the loss of two men now barith has led to cortez now barith is very sullen a very poor loser well you would be
这时他以非常莎士比亚的方式尖叫道，他声称他喊道：“圣母玛利亚，保护我，他们挖出了我的眼睛。”“圣母玛利亚，保护我，他们挖出了我的眼睛。”汤姆，我们需要那个吗？是的，显然你认为人们需要，但我不需要，我觉得你对他的模仿缺乏一种活力，我喜欢认为我提供了这一点。好吧，好吧，所以科尔特斯赢了，损失了两个人。纳尔瓦埃斯输给了科尔特斯，纳尔瓦埃斯非常阴沉，一个非常糟糕的失败者。嗯，你会的，
you've lost your eye and you've lost the battle it's embarrassing sullen, a very poor loser. Well, you would be, wouldn't you? You've lost your eye and you've lost the battle. It's embarrassing all around. He's a very poor loser, I think, Tom. He says, well, Captain Cortez,
你失去了眼睛，输掉了战斗。这很尴尬。阴沉，一个非常糟糕的失败者。嗯，你会的，不是吗？你失去了眼睛，输掉了战斗。这到处都很尴尬。我认为他是一个非常糟糕的失败者，汤姆。他说，好吧，科尔特斯船长，
you should be proud of yourself to have beaten me and taken me prisoner. And Cortez says, that's not my victory, but God's. And then he says, is that what he said?
你应该为你打败我并俘虏我而感到自豪。科尔特斯说，那不是我的胜利，而是上帝的。然后他说，他是这么说的吗？
He's like Terry Thomas. He says, I can assure you, this victory is the least brilliant I have yet gained in New Spain. You and your man, total shower. Yes, which is very, I think that's a bit ungracious. So everything has worked out for Cortez.
他就像特里·托马斯（Terry Thomas）。他说，我可以向你保证，这场胜利是我在“新西班牙”获得的成就中最不辉煌的一次。你和你的手下，简直是一群废物。是的，我认为这有点不客气。所以一切都对科尔特斯有利。
So Naves, he goes off to govern Florida, doesn't he, I think? Well, he goes off to try and explore Florida, and it all ends very badly for him, Tom. But we'll maybe leave that to the very last episode when we tell you what happened to all the characters. Yeah. So Cortes has won a tremendous win. His gamble has worked. He has now more than a thousand men because basically all the other Spaniards agreed to
所以纳尔瓦埃斯，他去统治佛罗里达了，对吧，我想？嗯，他去尝试探索佛罗里达，结果对他来说结局非常糟糕，汤姆。但也许我们会在最后一集告诉你们所有角色的结局时再讲。是的。所以科尔特斯赢得了巨大的胜利。他的冒险成功了。他现在有一千多人，因为基本上所有其他西班牙人都同意
join his company. He has 80 gunners. He has 80 crossbowmen. And so Dominic, as a result of this, he can now sit back, breathe a deep sigh of relief. Everything's going brilliantly, isn't it? Nothing could possibly go wrong. Nothing could go wrong. So he's in Veracruz, sorting everything out. Everything's great. And their messengers come from Tenochtitlan, Tom. Oh no. What are they saying? Yes. And they're Tlaxcalans. And they say,
加入他的公司。他有80名炮手。他有80名弩手。所以多米尼克，因此，他现在可以坐下来，长舒一口气。一切都进行得非常顺利，不是吗？什么都不会出错。什么都不会出错。所以他在韦拉克鲁斯，处理所有事情。一切都很棒。然后信使从特诺奇蒂特兰来了，汤姆。哦，不。他们在说什么？是的。他们是特拉斯卡拉人。他们说，
it's all falling apart. It's all going on in Tenochtitlan. What are you doing here on the coast? We're kicking off. It's all kicked off. The people of Tenochtitlan have turned on your Spanish friends. The capital is in flames, total chaos. Some of the Spaniards are dead. The rest of them are now besieged in the palace. They can't hold out much longer. The jeopardy is absolutely intense. And not that I'm going to quote from my own book, Tom, but I now will. Go on. There was no time to lose. They must ride for Tenochtitlan and war. Very Lord of the Rings. It is very.
一切都在分崩离析。特诺奇蒂特兰正在发生一切。你在海岸上做什么？我们正在开战。一切都开始了。特诺奇蒂特兰的人民已经反抗你的西班牙朋友了。首都陷入火海，一片混乱。一些西班牙人死了。其余的人现在被围困在宫殿里。他们坚持不了多久了。危机感绝对强烈。并不是我要引用我自己的书，汤姆，但我现在要引用了。说吧。没有时间可以浪费了。他们必须骑马前往特诺奇蒂特兰参战。非常《指环王》。确实非常像。
So I think he'd already sent a party, hadn't he? Before this news reaches him to go back to Tenochtitlan. And they are, I think, cornered in a mountain pass and wiped out to a man and a beast. That's right. Yes. But presumably. Yes. But presumably. Yes. With all these extra men, extra horses, crossbowmen and things,
所以我认为他已经派了一支队伍，不是吗？在这个消息传到他之前，去特诺奇蒂特兰。而且我认为，他们被困在山口，被全歼了，人马俱亡。没错。是的。但大概。是的。但大概。是的。有了所有这些额外的人、额外的马匹、弩手之类的，
effectively they're invincible, are they? Against kind of Bronze Age weaponry. Yes. I think they're not totally invincible, but it would take a pretty significant army to overpower them. If you think that swords are the key weapons, if you have a sword and you're fighting blokes with clubs, you can kill quite a few of them before they overpower you probably. I mean, you might be unlucky and killed
实际上他们是不可战胜的，对吧？对抗青铜时代的武器。是的。我认为他们不是完全不可战胜的，但需要一支相当大的军队才能压倒他们。如果你认为剑是关键武器，如果你有一把剑，而你在和拿着棍棒的家伙战斗，你可能在他们压倒你之前能杀死相当多的人。我的意思是，你可能会倒霉，被
by an arrow or spear or something, but you have horses, you have crossbows, you have some guns, you are quite a formidable prospect. Anyone who has played the game Civilization, in which you play various groups of people and you have to get them to the space age, and sometimes you will have entered the Renaissance and have cannon and horses and things. And you'll come up with an opponent who's still, you know, armed with clubs. Yeah, you're laughing. And you almost invariably win. So that is the parallel to bear in mind.
箭或长矛之类的东西杀死，但你有马，你有弩，你有枪，你是一个相当强大的对手。任何玩过《文明》游戏的人，在游戏中你扮演各种群体，你必须让他们进入太空时代，有时你已经进入了文艺复兴时期，有大炮和马匹之类的东西。你会遇到一个仍然拿着棍棒的对手。是的，你在笑。而且你几乎总是赢。所以这就是要记住的平行点。
That is the parallel. So Cortes sets off once again. It takes him three weeks to get back to the capital. He knows the route by now. But as they go over the mountains and they go down into the hidden garden of the Valley of Mexico towards the lake, Bernal Diaz says in his recollection, this great memoirist of respect was shown us here, nor did any of the chiefs call upon us. And that is a complete contrast with their first journey when people had turned out to see them very excited. Now the doors are closed. The glances are sullen and hostile.
这就是平行点。所以科尔特斯再次出发。他花了三个星期才回到首都。他现在知道路线了。但当他们翻过山脉，进入墨西哥谷的隐秘花园，朝湖泊走去时，伯纳尔·迪亚斯在回忆录中说，这位伟大的回忆录作者在这里向我们展示了，也没有任何酋长来拜访我们。这与他们第一次旅行时人们出来看他们、非常兴奋形成了鲜明的对比。现在门关上了。目光阴沉而充满敌意。
There's a kind of scary silence. But they advance unchallenged, Tom, which is remarkable. They go across the causeway, back into the city. It seems nobody is around. There's just this kind of deathly silence. They managed to get to the palace where they had left, where Pedro de Alvarado is holed up. They're not attacked, which seems to me slightly mysterious. I don't actually understand, to be completely honest, why people don't organize some kind of ambush against them. Maybe they just too intimidated i don't know yeah i mean would the news have reached them i i mean if moctezuma is a prisoner perhaps the chain of command has been so fractured that
有一种可怕的沉默。但他们前进时没有受到挑战，汤姆，这很了不起。他们穿过堤道，回到城里。似乎周围没有人。只有这种死一般的寂静。他们设法到达了他们离开的宫殿，佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多被困在那里。他们没有受到攻击，这对我来说似乎有点神秘。老实说，我不明白为什么人们不组织某种伏击来对付他们。也许他们太害怕了，我不知道。是的，我的意思是消息会传到他们那里吗？我的意思是，如果蒙特祖马是囚犯，也许指挥链已经断裂到
it's broken down it's broken down in some way yes you know it's been decapitated the spy network or something i mean who who knows i don't Yes. But Cortez gets to the palace and there Pedro de Alvarado is waiting. And Cortez says, what has happened? What on earth is going on? And we'll find out, Tom, after the break.
它崩溃了，它以某种方式崩溃了，是的，你知道它被斩首了，间谍网络之类的，我的意思是，谁知道呢，我不知道。是的。但科尔特斯到达了宫殿，佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多在那里等着。科尔特斯说，发生了什么事？到底发生了什么？我们休息后会知道的，汤姆。
Brilliant. Very exciting. Huge more excitements to come. We'll see you back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
太棒了。非常令人兴奋。还有更多巨大的兴奋即将到来。几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，那是
therestisentertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello and welcome back to the rest is history and things are really kicking off in the great capital of the mexica cortez has returned triumphant from his venture to the coast he comes bringing all kinds of reinforcements and weaponry. He has reached Tenochtitlan, and there he's met with Pedro de Alvarado, who he had left in command in the capital. And Dominic, you left us on this cliffhanger, Cortés asking Alvarado, what has been happening while I've been away? So what has been happening while Cortés was away? So let's start with Alvarado himself. It's important to understand Alvarado's personality. He cheats at games.
therestisentertainment.com，那是《历史的余味》。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，墨西加的大首都正在发生大事。科尔特斯从海岸的冒险中凯旋归来。他带来了各种增援部队和武器。他已经到达了特诺奇蒂特兰，在那里他见到了佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多，他把阿尔瓦拉多留在了首都指挥。多米尼克，你把我们留在这个悬念中，科尔特斯问阿尔瓦拉多，我不在的时候发生了什么？那么科尔特斯不在的时候发生了什么？让我们从阿尔瓦拉多本人开始。了解阿尔瓦拉多的个性很重要。他在游戏中作弊。
He does cheat at games. We discussed that last time. Alvarado is a direct contemporary of Cortes, born in the same year, probably 1485, born in Extremadura. He'd been probably more successful than Cortes in his kind of Caribbean enterprises. He owned a big hacienda on Cuba.
他确实在游戏中作弊。我们上次讨论过。阿尔瓦拉多是科尔特斯的直接同代人，出生在同一年，大概是1485年，出生在埃斯特雷马杜拉。他在加勒比海的企业中可能比科尔特斯更成功。他在古巴拥有一座大庄园。
Everybody says of Pedro de Alvarado, he's a great swashbuckler. He's a lad, isn't he? He's a lad. He owned a big hacienda on Cuba. Everybody says of Pedro de Alvarado, he's a great swashbuckler. He's a lad, isn't he? He's a lad. He's a Flashman-type character, actually, but not with Flashman's cowardice. He is a big man. He's handsome.
每个人都说佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多是一个伟大的剑客。他是个小伙子，不是吗？他是个小伙子。他在古巴拥有一座大庄园。每个人都说佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多是一个伟大的剑客。他是个小伙子，不是吗？他是个小伙子。他是一个“闪光人”式的人物，实际上，但没有闪光人的懦弱。他是一个大个子。他很英俊。
He has golden hair. He is charming. Slaps his thigh. Ha, ha, ha, ha. He is always very well-dressed. He's incredibly brave. It was always said of him that he had climbed the Giralda as a young man or as a boy in Seville, and people had watched in terror as he showed his courage in climbing this great tower.
他有金色的头发。他很有魅力。拍打着大腿。哈哈哈哈。他总是穿得很好。他非常勇敢。人们总是说他年轻时或在塞维利亚还是个男孩时就爬上了吉拉尔达塔（Giralda），人们惊恐地看着他展示爬上这座伟大塔楼的勇气。
He's very affable. He's very flamboyant. He has gold chains and all this. He'd be a terrible man to go on a stag party with, wouldn't he? He would, actually. He'd get you into terrible trouble. It would be exhausting, and you'd end up arrested. Yeah.
他非常和蔼可亲。他非常浮夸。他有金链子和所有这些东西。他会是一个去参加单身派对的糟糕人选，不是吗？他确实会。他会让你陷入可怕的麻烦。这会让人筋疲力尽，你最终会被捕。是的。
He's like the young Henry VIII or something. Yeah. He's a man who today would be wearing a gilet. I think it's fair to say. He would. Yeah. He would be wearing a kind of, I don't know, a Hackett branded gilet or something like that.
他就像年轻的亨利八世之类的。是的。他是一个今天会穿背心的人。我认为可以这么说。他会。是的。他会穿某种，我不知道，哈克特（Hackett）品牌的背心之类的。
Anyway, that's by the by. He'd have loads of great girlfriends. He'd all be very posh. He would. They'd all be called Minty, his girlfriend, or something like that. Anyway, that's by the by. He'd have loads of great girlfriends who'd all be very posh. He would. They'd all be called Minty, his girlfriend, or something like that. Oh, Pedro. He'd go on yachting holidays. Put it away.
总之，那是题外话。他会有很多很棒的女朋友。她们都会很时髦。他会。她们都会叫明蒂（Minty），他的女朋友，或者类似的名字。总之，那是题外话。他会有很多很棒的女朋友，她们都会很时髦。他会。她们都会叫明蒂，他的女朋友，或者类似的名字。哦，佩德罗。他会去游艇度假。收起来。
Yes. Yeah. So the Aztecs call him the son, Tonatia, because of his blonde hair and his sort of demeanor. So again, this weird lack of anyone with black hair in the Spanish ranks. Yes. Okay. They're all blonde or ginger. Very odd. Yeah. This is an aspect. So again, this weird lack of anyone with black hair in the Spanish ranks. Yes, okay. They're all blonde or ginger. Very odd.
是的。是的。所以阿兹特克人称他为太阳，托纳蒂乌（Tonatiuh），因为他金色的头发和他的举止。所以再次，西班牙队伍中没有黑发的人这种奇怪的缺乏。是的。好吧。他们都是金发或姜黄色。非常奇怪。是的。这是一个方面。所以再次，西班牙队伍中没有黑发的人这种奇怪的缺乏。是的，好吧。他们都是金发或姜黄色。非常奇怪。
Yeah, this is an aspect. I know you've been roaming the land giving talks about Roman hairstyles, haven't you, Tom? Yeah, I have. So surely the conquistador's hair is something that's been unexplored. It's an aspect that has grown over the course of these episodes. And Theo points out, he says, this is after Al-Andalus. It's after the Moorish influence on Spain. So what on earth is going on? Why don't they all have dark hair? Well points out, he says, this is after Al-Andalus. It's after the Moorish influence on Spain. So what on earth is going on?
是的，这是一个方面。我知道你一直在全国各地做关于罗马发型的演讲，不是吗，汤姆？是的，我有。所以征服者的头发肯定是一个未被探索的领域。这是一个在这些剧集过程中逐渐增长的方面。西奥指出，他说，这是在安达卢斯（Al-Andalus）之后。这是在摩尔人对西班牙的影响之后。所以到底发生了什么？为什么他们不都有黑头发？好吧，指出，他说，这是在安达卢斯之后。这是在摩尔人对西班牙的影响之后。所以到底发生了什么？
Why don't they all have dark hair? Well, anyway, he doesn't. Cortes has left him in charge and he is a very bad man to have left in charge because he's unreliable. Yeah. You know.
为什么他们不都有黑头发？好吧，总之，他没有。科尔特斯让他负责，他是一个非常糟糕的负责人，因为他不可靠。是的。你知道。
A bloody top laugh. Let's massacre everyone in the temple. Because, of course, also the context, Tom, is that everything is incredibly uncertain because Montezuma is a prisoner. I mean, he is the center of the Aztec world. He is the guy that does all the sacrifices.
一个血腥的顶级笑话。让我们屠杀神庙里的每个人。因为，当然，背景，汤姆，是所有事情都极其不确定，因为蒙特祖马是囚犯。我的意思是，他是阿兹特克世界的中心。他是做所有祭祀的人。
And they're having to kind of disguise it, that he's a prisoner. They are. And there's a growing sense, one chronicler, Nahuatl chronicler says, fear reigned as if everyone had lost heart. Even before it grew dark, everyone huddled and frightened groups everybody slept in terror so presumably that's the reason why people in the capital haven't taken full advantage of cortez's departure and tried to block his return i would guess yes because there's a tremendous uncertainty the people of the city are confused the emperor is not dead is he a prisoner is he a hostage is he a guest they don't know well also am i not right that there are rival factions within the court of course that there are people who identify with
他们不得不掩盖他是囚犯的事实。他们是。而且有一种日益增长的感觉，一位纳瓦特尔编年史家说，恐惧统治着，仿佛每个人都失去了勇气。甚至在天黑之前，每个人都蜷缩在受惊的群体中，每个人都在恐惧中睡觉，所以大概这就是为什么首都的人们没有充分利用科尔特斯的离开并试图阻止他返回的原因，我会猜是的，因为有一种巨大的不确定性，城市里的人们很困惑，皇帝没有死，他是囚犯吗？他是人质吗？他是客人吗？他们不知道，好吧，我说的对吗，宫廷内部有敌对派系，当然，有些人认同
opponents to the spaniards and then there are others often moctezuma's own sons who identify with the policy of trying to arrive at an accommodation with them yes all courts are prone to factionalism there's no reason to believe that the courts in Tenochtitlan would be any different. As you said before, Tom, last week, they don't have primogeniture. No. So it's up for grabs, isn't it? Succession is up for grabs. There must always have been people who had hoped that the succession would one day pass to them, or maybe resented the fact that Montezuma had got it in the first place 18 years earlier. So we have no insight into those kind of deliberations. What we do know is that over time, Alvarado and the Spaniards become incredibly jittery,
西班牙人的反对者，然后有其他人，通常是蒙特祖马自己的儿子，他们认同试图与他们达成妥协的政策，是的，所有宫廷都容易出现派系斗争，没有理由相信特诺奇蒂特兰的宫廷会有什么不同。正如你之前所说，汤姆，上周，他们没有长子继承制。不。所以这是可以争夺的，不是吗？继承权是可以争夺的。一定总有人希望继承权有一天能传给他们，或者可能怨恨蒙特祖马在18年前首先得到了它。所以我们对那些审议没有洞察力。我们所知道的是，随着时间的推移，阿尔瓦拉多和西班牙人变得极其紧张，
and they start to tell stories about the servants are no longer turning up, their supplies of food. They can't go and get their own food from the market because they're worried they'll be set upon. They require people to bring them food from the market. They are not getting food from the market. The story goes that one of the girls, the young women who washes their laundry, is found hanged outside the palace. Now, maybe this is one of those kind of stories that is told afterwards, but isn't really true. But it gives you a sense into their mentality. And again, this is a kind of primal colonial narrative, isn't it? The European adventurers who have gone too far, too deep. Yes.
他们开始讲述仆人不再出现，他们的食物供应的故事。他们不能去市场买自己的食物，因为他们担心会被袭击。他们要求人们从市场给他们带食物。他们没有从市场得到食物。故事说，其中一个洗衣服的女孩被发现吊死在宫殿外。现在，也许这是事后讲述的那种故事，但并不是真的。但这让你对他们的心态有了一个了解。而且再次，这是一种原始的殖民叙事，不是吗？走得太远、太深的欧洲冒险家。是的。
And find themselves surrounded. And the question then becomes, should you stick or should you get out? Yes. It's so true, Tom. Yeah. You know, you get it in Kabul and in a sense, you get it with the American embassy in Saigon. I mean, this is a very long story. It is.
发现自己被包围了。然后问题就变成了，你应该坚持还是应该离开？是的。太真实了，汤姆。是的。你知道，你在喀布尔会遇到这种情况，在某种意义上，你在西贡的美国大使馆也会遇到这种情况。我的意思是，这是一个很长的故事。它是。
And this is the first iteration of it, really. It is the first iteration of it. Yeah, I'm just thinking about it now. We did the podcast about General Gordon in Khartoum. Yeah, General Gordon, of course, another classic example. Yeah. Surrounded, you know. But this is the first and most striking version of those stories about the European colonizers
而且这确实是它的第一次迭代。它是它的第一次迭代。是的，我现在正在考虑它。我们做了关于喀土穆戈登将军的播客。是的，戈登将军，当然，另一个经典的例子。是的。被包围，你知道。但这是关于欧洲殖民者的那些故事的第一个也是最引人注目的版本。
who are trapped in a world they don't understand. Because now the city is gearing up for another of these big religious festivals this is the feast of tosh cattle when warriors will dance before a huge effigy of the god witsilaposhli the most beloved of all the aztecs gods the patron of the mexica and alvarado according to later accounts is starting to get warnings from informants particularly from tlaxcala. So there are still clearly some Tlaxcalans there. Some say, at this festival, you and the other leaders of the Spaniards are going to be tied up and people are going to tear your hearts out.
他们被困在一个他们无法理解的世界里。因为现在这座城市正在为另一场大型宗教节日做准备，这就是托什卡特尔节（Feast of Tosh Cattle），届时勇士们将在战神维齐洛波奇特利（Witsilaposhli）的巨大雕像前跳舞，他是所有阿兹特克神中最受爱戴的一位，是墨西加人的守护神。据后来的记载，阿尔瓦拉多（Alvarado）开始收到来自线人的警告，特别是来自特拉斯卡拉（Tlaxcala）的线人。所以那里显然还有一些特拉斯卡拉人。有人说，在这个节日里，你和其他西班牙人的首领会被绑起来，人们会挖出你们的心脏。
Others say, that's probably not going to happen. What's actually going to happen is people are planning to break into the palace and rescue Montezuma and kill you all. Some people say they're tunneling under the walls. There's one Spaniards account, which is that the Aztecs are preparing to cook them in giant pots with garlic, which fills the Spaniards with horror. Of course, this might be the Tlaxcalans causing trouble. Of course it might be. As they did in Cholula.
另一些人说，这可能不会发生。真正会发生的是，人们正计划闯入宫殿，救出蒙特祖马（Montezuma），并杀死你们所有人。有些人说他们正在墙下挖地道。有一个西班牙人的说法是，阿兹特克人正准备用大锅加蒜把他们煮了，这让西班牙人感到恐惧。当然，这可能是特拉斯卡拉人在捣乱。当然有可能是这样。就像他们在乔鲁拉（Cholula）所做的那样。
Yes. They're worried the Spaniards are too close to the Aztecs and they want to turn them against them. But presumably also that the Spaniards aren't speaking N Now what? I mean, they don't really know. No. It's a projection of their worst nightmares. And Melinche is off with Cortes, so she's not translating for them. Yes, exactly. And so the notion that the people around them are cannibals and
是的。他们担心西班牙人与阿兹特克人走得太近，想让他们反目成仇。但大概也是因为西班牙人不会说纳瓦特尔语，现在怎么办？我的意思是，他们真的不知道。不。这是他们内心最深处噩梦的投射。梅林切（Melinche）和科尔特斯（Cortes）在一起，所以她没有为他们翻译。是的，完全正确。所以，他们周围的人是食人族和
sacrifices and everything, if that's what you think, then your nightmares are going to breed all kinds of terrifying fantasies. So none of them might be true, but it doesn't mean that they're not in terrible danger, of course. No, of course. I think that's exactly it. Even if these stories are totally untrue, A, it gives you a clue into what the specters that are haunting the imagination of the Spaniards, and B, it doesn't mean that they're safe. They are in terrible danger. The festival begins in mid-May, and there's all kinds you described in that beautiful beautifully written passage that you read at the beginning of the episode yeah there's
祭祀者等等，如果你是这么想的，那么你的噩梦就会滋生出各种可怕的幻想。所以这些可能都不是真的，但这并不意味着他们没有处于极度危险之中，当然。不，当然。我想正是这样。即使这些故事完全不真实，A，它也为你提供了关于困扰西班牙人想象力的幽灵的线索，B，这并不意味着他们是安全的。他们处于极度危险之中。节日从五月中旬开始，正如你在本集开头读到的那段优美的文字中所描述的那样，有各种各样的
all kinds of drumming and dancing and all of this kind of business the end of the festival will be that a sacrificial victim will go up to the temple that he will turn to face the lake he will be carrying a flute he will break it in two and then he will be killed and his heart will be taken out. That is how it is meant to end. But before that can happen, Pedro de Alvarado, Mr. Gile, he completely loses his cool. And he says to his men, this is it, we're all going to be killed. We must act first as we did in Cholula. A very good indigenous account of this comes from something called the Florentine Codex, which was told by indigenous people to, I think, Franciscan friars. So there is an element of cross-cultural contamination. There is.
各种击鼓和舞蹈以及所有这些活动，节日的结尾将是一名祭品走上神庙，他会转身面向湖泊，手里拿着一支长笛，他会把它折成两半，然后他会被杀掉，心脏会被挖出来。这就是它本该结束的方式。但在那之前，佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多（Pedro de Alvarado），吉尔先生（Mr. Gile），他完全失去了冷静。他对部下说，就是现在，我们都要被杀了。我们必须像在乔鲁拉那样先发制人。一个非常好的土著记载来自所谓的《佛罗伦萨手抄本》（Florentine Codex），这是由土著人讲述给，我想是方济各会修士听的。所以这里有一种跨文化污染的成分。确实有。
It's not entirely reliable, I think it's fair to say. But it's more reliable in giving the Mexica perspective. It is. Than Diaz's accounts. and so this goes as follows the festivity was being observed and there was dancing and singing with voices raised in song the singing was like the noise of waves breaking against the rocks when the moment had come for the spaniards to do their killing they came out equipped for battle they came and closed off each of the places where people went in and out when they'd closed those exits they stationed themselves
我认为公平地说，它并不完全可靠。但在提供墨西加人的视角方面，它比迪亚斯（Diaz）的记载更可靠。确实是。所以情况如下：节日正在进行，人们载歌载舞，歌声嘹亮，歌声就像海浪拍打岩石的声音。当西班牙人进行杀戮的时刻到来时，他们全副武装地走了出来，他们封锁了人们进出的每一个地方，当他们封锁了这些出口后，他们就驻扎在
in each and no one could come out. And when this had been done, they went into the temple courtyard to kill people. Those whose assignment it was to do the killing just went on foot, each with his metal sword and leather shield. Then they surrounded those who were dancing, going among the cylindrical drums. They struck a drummer's arms.
每一个出口，没有人能出来。当这一切完成后，他们进入神庙庭院开始杀人。那些被指派进行杀戮的人徒步前进，每个人都带着金属剑和皮盾。然后他们包围了那些正在跳舞的人，穿梭在圆柱形的鼓之间。他们砍断了一名鼓手的双臂。
Both of his hands were severed. Then they struck his neck. His head landed far away. Then they stabbed everyone with iron lances and struck them with iron lances and struck them with iron swords they struck some in the belly and their entrails came spilling out those who tried to escape could go nowhere when anyone tried to go out they struck and stabbed him the blood flowed like water and gathered into pools the pools began to grow and the stench of blood
他的双手被砍断了。然后他们砍向他的脖子。他的头落在了很远的地方。然后他们用铁矛刺向所有人，用铁矛和铁剑攻击他们，他们刺向一些人的腹部，肠子流了出来，那些试图逃跑的人无处可去，当有人试图出去时，他们就攻击并刺伤他，鲜血像水一样流淌，汇集成池，血池开始扩大，血腥味
and guts filled the air so the thing that immediately strikes you about that is that from the spanish perspective the idea of sacrificing to a god at a festival is hideous it's what demons demand and yet they are spilling more blood at this festival now than the mashika would ever have done yes because they're killing hundreds of people and there's a kind of grim irony there isn't there yeah there is absolutely they're killing hundreds of people. And there's a kind of grim irony there, isn't there? Yeah, there is absolutely. They're killing hundreds of people, men, women, and children, totally unarmed. And taking them by surprise at a festival. So it's kind of like a terrorist attack at a Christmas fair or something. To the Mexica, and indeed to the modern reader, this is utterly appalling behavior.
和内脏的味道弥漫在空气中。所以，关于这一点，最让你震惊的是，从西班牙人的角度来看，在节日里向神献祭的想法是极其丑陋的，那是恶魔所要求的，然而他们现在在这个节日里流下的血比墨西加人曾经做过的还要多。是的，因为他们杀了几百人，这有一种冷酷的讽刺意味，不是吗？是的，确实如此。他们杀了几百人。这有一种冷酷的讽刺意味，不是吗？是的，确实如此。他们杀了几百人，男人、女人和孩子，完全手无寸铁。并在节日里搞突然袭击。所以这有点像在圣诞集市上发生的恐怖袭击之类的。对于墨西加人，乃至现代读者来说，这都是极其令人震惊的行为。
I mean, it is monstrous behavior. They are striking civilians. I mean, they're doing it out of terror. They're doing it because they think they have no choice, of course, but they're also doing it in order to terrify, I think, aren't they? They're laying down a marker. As they did in Cholula. Yes, as they did in Cholula. Now, the difference with Cholula is Tenochtitlan is too big. So they've closed the gates of the square and started to kill everybody inside the square,
我的意思是，这是极其残暴的行为。他们在攻击平民。我的意思是，他们这样做是出于恐惧。他们这样做是因为他们认为自己别无选择，当然，但我认为他们这样做也是为了制造恐怖，不是吗？他们在立威。就像他们在乔鲁拉所做的那样。是的，就像他们在乔鲁拉所做的那样。现在，与乔鲁拉的区别在于特诺奇蒂特兰（Tenochtitlan）太大了。所以他们关闭了广场的大门，开始杀掉广场里的每一个人，
hundreds of people. But beyond the gates, people are shouting, supposedly, lords of the Mexica, hasten, hurry, prepare your weapons, hasten, hurry. We are betrayed. Our warriors are being slaughtered. And people are trying to burst to get into the square. The gates give way. Hundreds of people who have armed themselves with clubs and obsidian, black volcanic glass, knives and things, come storming into the square. The Spanish now fall back. They are under attack. Alvarado is hit by a stone on the head which he greatly resents.
几百人。但在大门外，人们据称在喊：“墨西加的领主们，快，快，准备武器，快，快。我们被出卖了。我们的勇士正在被屠杀。”人们试图冲进广场。大门被冲破了。数百名用棍棒和黑曜石（黑色火山玻璃）、刀具等武装起来的人冲进了广场。西班牙人现在撤退了。他们受到了攻击。阿尔瓦拉多头部被石头击中，他对此感到非常愤怒。
Bloody hell. Yeah. It's not sporting behaviour. Yeah. But he manages to gather his men, form them up, lead them back to the palace of Axeacatl in a sort of fighting retreat. They get back to the palace. Now meanwhile, while he's been out, the rest of his men who were left in the palace, he had ordered them to start killing the prisoners. So they must have had more prisoners. They must have had some
该死。是的。这不符合体育精神。是的。但他设法召集了他的部下，排好队形，带领他们以一种战斗撤退的方式退回阿克萨卡特尔（Axeacatl）的宫殿。他们回到了宫殿。现在与此同时，当他外出时，他留在宫殿里的其余部下，他曾命令他们开始杀害囚犯。所以他们一定还有更多的囚犯。他们一定还有一些
other hostages, members of Montezuma's family, noblemen, advisors of Montezuma's. They've killed some of them, so there are bodies in the palace. And Dominic, what is the timeframe with this in relation to Cortes? Cortes is rushing back to Tenerife land with his reinforcements. Does Alvarado know that Cortez is imminent? I mean, when will Cortez get back? I don't think Cortez is on the scene yet. I'm not certain because we can't be sure exactly when this happened, I think. Historians guess, but I'm not sure we exactly know. And we also don't know exactly what Alvarado knows. I think he's not thinking about it that coolly, actually,
其他人质，蒙特祖马的家人、贵族、蒙特祖马的顾问。他们杀了一些人，所以宫殿里有尸体。多米尼克（Dominic），这与科尔特斯的时间线是什么关系？科尔特斯正带着增援部队赶回特诺奇蒂特兰。阿尔瓦拉多知道科尔特斯快到了吗？我的意思是，科尔特斯什么时候回来？我不认为科尔特斯已经在现场了。我不确定，因为我们无法确定这件事确切发生在什么时候，我想。历史学家在猜测，但我不知道我们是否确切知道。而且我们也不知道阿尔瓦拉多确切知道什么。我认为他其实并没有那么冷静地思考，
in such a calculated way. He's just lashing out. I think he's lashing out and thinking, hoping that Cortes will get back and bail him out. Because otherwise they're completely screwed either way. Because otherwise, yes. Yeah. So he gets back. Montezuma is still alive.
以那种经过计算的方式。他只是在发泄。我认为他是在发泄，并想着，希望科尔特斯能回来救他。因为否则他们无论如何都彻底完了。因为否则，是的。是的。所以他回来了。蒙特祖马还活着。
Montezuma is now, without any shadow of a doubt, their hostage, their prisoner. By nightfall, they're all back in the palace again with Montezuma is now without any shadow of a doubt they're hostage they're prisoner by nightfall they're all back in the palace again with montezuma there is a huge crowd outside hammering on the gates there are spanish kind of firing crossbows at the people i'm outside they bring montezuma out onto the roof it's extraordinary scene alvarado is there with a knife. Montezuma is there. And there's another guy called Itzcoatzin, who is the lord of Tlatelolco, which is the market, the suburb that's the market. And Itzcoatzin says to the crowd, people of the Mexica, put down your weapons. Montezuma asks you to put your weapons down. We can't win. Return to your homes. You know, all this.
蒙特祖马现在毫无疑问是他们的人质，他们的囚犯。天黑时，他们都回到了宫殿，蒙特祖马现在毫无疑问是他们的人质，他们的囚犯。天黑时，他们都回到了宫殿，蒙特祖马在那里，外面有大批人群在敲打大门，西班牙人向外面的人发射弩箭。他们把蒙特祖马带到屋顶上，这是一个非凡的场景。阿尔瓦拉多拿着刀在那里。蒙特祖马在那里。还有另一个人叫伊兹科阿特辛（Itzcoatzin），他是特拉特洛尔科（Tlatelolco）的领主，那是市场，是作为市场的郊区。伊兹科阿特辛对人群说：“墨西加的人民，放下你们的武器。蒙特祖马要求你们放下武器。我们赢不了。回到你们的家中。”你知道，所有这些。
So can I just ask, though? Yeah. I mean, again, where are we getting this from? Well, here you go, Tom. Here you go. Every single detail of this story, we are taking on trust, either from Spanish sources like Bernal Diaz or Gomara, who was later Cortez's secretary. Hagiographer, one might say.
所以我能问一下吗？是的。我的意思是，同样，我们是从哪里得到这些信息的？好吧，给你，汤姆。给你。这个故事的每一个细节，我们都是基于信任，要么来自西班牙的消息来源，比如贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯（Bernal Diaz）或后来担任科尔特斯秘书的戈马拉（Gomara）。有人可能会说，是传记作者。
Bernard Diaz said, don't believe a word Gomara says is making it all up. Bernard Diaz is saying that then. Yeah. Or we're getting it from the so-called indigenous accounts. But quite a lot of those indigenous accounts are being written down by Spaniards, by Franciscans and so on. But also some of these accounts are coming from members of Moctezuma's family. Yes.
贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯说，别相信戈马拉说的任何话，他都是编造的。贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯当时是这么说的。是的。或者我们是从所谓的土著记载中得到的。但其中相当多的土著记载是由西班牙人、方济各会修士等记录下来的。但其中一些记载也来自蒙特祖马的家人。是的。
And they are concerned to preserve their lands, aren't they? Exactly. So if they can cast Moctezuma as pliant and submissive to the Spanish king. Exactly right. Then that's good for them. Everybody has an agenda. Which in turn isn't to say that it's completely implausible, because it could well be. I mean, I think that this is what makes best sense of Moctezuma's behavior, is that he has arrived at the conclusion that there is no prospect of stopping the Spaniards. He's turned into Denethor in Lord of the Rings.
他们关心的是保住他们的土地，不是吗？完全正确。所以如果他们能把蒙特祖马塑造成对西班牙国王顺从和屈服的样子。完全正确。那对他们有好处。每个人都有自己的议程。这并不是说这完全不可信，因为它很可能是真的。我的意思是，我认为这最能解释蒙特祖马的行为，那就是他已经得出结论，没有阻止西班牙人的希望。他变成了《指环王》里的德内梭尔（Denethor）。
Oh, crikey, Tom. That's a good comparison. He's in despair. Yeah. You know, he's gazed into the mirror and he has seen the seas teeming with mighty ships with iron and horses. So, I mean, the simple answer is we don't know. I mean, we will never have a conclusive answer to it. No. But, I mean, by the way, one other aspect of the indigenous sources, some of them are written
哦，天哪，汤姆。这是一个很好的比较。他陷入了绝望。是的。你知道，他凝视着镜子，看到了大海中挤满了强大的船只，带着铁器和马匹。所以，简单的回答是我们不知道。我的意思是，我们永远不会有一个确定的答案。不。但是，顺便说一句，土著来源的另一个方面，其中一些是
by the Mexica's enemies, so by the Tlaxcalans and so on. That's yet another dimension. I think it's plausible, it's absolutely plausible that they would bring him out onto the roof and that he would say, go back to your homes. Lay down your arms. Because he's got a knife at his throat, for one thing. What I also think is plausible is another detail that we have, which is that somebody in the crowd shouts, and this in such a regimented world as that of the Aztecs would be a remarkable moment, that somebody shouts, who is Montezuma now to give us orders?
由墨西加人的敌人写的，比如特拉斯卡拉人等等。这是另一个维度。我认为这是可信的，绝对可信的是，他们会把他带到屋顶上，他会说，回到你们的家中。放下你们的武器。因为首先，他的喉咙上有一把刀。我认为同样可信的另一个细节是，人群中有人喊道，在一个像阿兹特克人那样纪律严明的世界里，这将是一个非凡的时刻，有人喊道：“蒙特祖马现在算什么，能给我们下命令？”
Why should we listen to Montezuma? He has lost his authority. I think there's no doubt that he must have lost a lot of his authority at this point. Because the image that is often there in the sort of orthodox European histories is of the Aztecs as this uniquely passive, superstitious, childish people. Their emperor has been taken prisoner and they just don't know what to do and they are so confused and bewildered and all of this. I think that's... I mean, lots of people are confused and bewildered, but that doesn't mean they don't have agency and it doesn't mean they don't have agendas of their own. No, well, they don't. But also,
“我们为什么要听蒙特祖马的？他已经失去了权威。”我认为毫无疑问，他此时一定失去了很多权威。因为在某种正统的欧洲历史中，阿兹特克人通常被描绘成一种极其被动、迷信、幼稚的民族。他们的皇帝被俘虏了，他们只是不知道该怎么办，他们感到非常困惑和不知所措等等。我认为那是……我的意思是，很多人感到困惑和不知所措，但这并不意味着他们没有能动性，也不意味着他们没有自己的议程。不，好吧，他们没有。但同样，
Moctezuma is very, very experienced. He's had what? He's 18 years, is it? He's been ruler. He's very proficient. He's a very hard man, but he has had time to talk to Malinche, to talk to Cortes. So his perspective may be that of the sober elder, but presumably the guys who are howling for blood at the base of the palace are warriors for whom none of these considerations matter. Yeah, it's a very good point. They're probably young. They're probably guys in their late teens, early twenties, fired up. By the way, there's just been a huge massacre and they are out for blood. So the attack redoubles, they ignore Montezuma. And it's sometime after this, some days after this, that Cortes had arrived. So this is the story that Alvarado tells to Cortes. And now, of course, Cortes has walked into the trap too. But all that background makes it even weirder that Cortvarado tells to Cortez. And now, of course, Cortez has walked into the trap too. But all that background makes it even weirder that Cortez is able to get in. I know.
蒙特祖马非常有经验。他当了多久？18年，是吗？他一直是统治者。他非常精明。他是一个非常强硬的人，但他有时间与梅林切交谈，与科尔特斯交谈。所以他的视角可能是清醒的长者的视角，但大概那些在宫殿底部为鲜血而嚎叫的人是勇士，对他们来说，这些考虑都不重要。是的，这是一个很好的观点。他们可能很年轻。他们可能是十几岁到二十出头的人，被点燃了。顺便说一句，刚刚发生了一场大屠杀，他们渴望鲜血。所以攻击加倍了，他们无视蒙特祖马。在这之后不久，几天之后，科尔特斯到达了。所以这就是阿尔瓦拉多告诉科尔特斯的故事。现在，当然，科尔特斯也走进了陷阱。但所有这些背景使得科尔特斯能够进入变得更加奇怪。我知道。
I agree with you. I totally agree with you. Sense of something not quite right there, perhaps? Well, is there a lacuna in the story? Or is it a trap? Yeah, maybe. Did the Mexica say, this other guy's pitching up. Let's let him walk straight in.
我同意你的看法。我完全同意你的看法。感觉那里有些不对劲，也许？好吧，故事里有缺口吗？还是这是一个陷阱？是的，也许。墨西加人是不是说，这个家伙要来了。让他直接走进来。
And then he'll be bottled up too. I mean, that's possible. Okay. Yes, I can see that. Yes. But you're right, Tom. I do feel like there's something missing there. Why didn't they attack Cortez? Why did they let him walk across the causeway? Anyway, he has come across the causeway and now he has this dilemma. What on earth is he going to do? Montezuma is his hostage. He could do a deal with Montezuma, but actually Cortez seems to have given up on Montezuma is his hostage. He could do a deal with Montezuma, but actually Cortes seems to have given up on Montezuma at this point. He says, Montezuma was talking to Narbiath behind my back. I don't trust him. He's lost his power. Forget about him. They have one of Montezuma's
然后他也会被困住。我的意思是，这是可能的。好的。是的，我能看出来。是的。但你是对的，汤姆。我确实觉得那里缺少了一些东西。为什么他们不攻击科尔特斯？为什么他们让他走过堤道？无论如何，他已经走过了堤道，现在他面临这个困境。他到底要怎么办？蒙特祖马是他的人质。他可以和蒙特祖马达成协议，但实际上科尔特斯似乎已经放弃了蒙特祖马。他说：“蒙特祖马在我背后和纳尔瓦埃斯（Narbiath）交谈。我不信任他。他失去了权力。忘了他吧。”他们有蒙特祖马的一个
brothers, a guy called Cuitlahuaq. They say to him, will you go and get us supplies from the market? This is very, do you know what this reminds me of? It's when Julius Caesar was holed up in Alexandria and he kept releasing Cleopatra's brothers who then went and betrayed him. And this is that again. He releases this guy's brother, off he goes, and he immediately incites the crowd and says, you know, we shouldn't do any deal with the Spaniards. They're terrible people and all this. And don't they start pulling up the causeways at this point? Yes, exactly. The Nesica start to demolish and block the causeways. They don't want the Spaniards to get out. They've got them where they want them. Cortes knows that the western
兄弟，一个叫奎特拉瓦克（Cuitlahuaq）的人。他们对他说：“你能去市场为我们弄些补给吗？”这非常，你知道这让我想起了什么吗？就像尤利乌斯·凯撒（Julius Caesar）被困在亚历山大港时，他不断释放克利奥帕特拉（Cleopatra）的兄弟，他们后来背叛了他。这又是那样的情况。他释放了这个人的兄弟，他走了，并立即煽动人群说：“你知道，我们不应该和西班牙人做任何交易。他们是可怕的人等等。”他们此时不是开始拆除堤道了吗？是的，完全正确。墨西加人开始拆除和封锁堤道。他们不想让西班牙人出去。他们把他们困在了他们想要的地方。科尔特斯知道西部的
causeway is still open. He sends his friend Diego de Odaf to go and try and investigate. He only gets a short way, a few streets, and then has to retreat under a hail of stones and arrows. So now it's very clear the Spaniards are trapped. They have very little food, very little fresh water. We don't know how many of them there are. We do know that Cortes came with a thousand men. So that's a lot of people to feed. Yeah, right.
堤道仍然是开放的。他派他的朋友迭戈·德·奥达斯（Diego de Odaf）去调查。他只走了一小段路，几条街，然后不得不在石头和箭雨下撤退。所以现在很清楚，西班牙人被困住了。他们几乎没有食物，几乎没有淡水。我们不知道他们有多少人。我们确实知道科尔特斯带了一千人。所以那是很多人要养活。是的，没错。
They're raging. Come and get the gold and find yourself holed up in a palace. They're furious. Absolutely furious. This is not what they'd sign up for at all. The worst holiday ever. There must be some Tlaxcalans and maybe Totonacs, we don't know,
他们很愤怒。来拿黄金，结果发现自己被困在宫殿里。他们很愤怒。绝对愤怒。这根本不是他们签约时所期望的。有史以来最糟糕的假期。一定有一些特拉斯卡拉人和可能是托托纳克人（Totonacs），我们不知道，
lurking around as well. How many of them? It's impossible to say. Among the Spaniards, you can imagine them kind of there, camped in corridors and chambers and bedrooms and whatever of this palace, crammed in, sweaty,
也在潜伏。他们有多少人？无法说。在西班牙人中间，你可以想象他们在那儿，露营在走廊、房间、卧室和这座宫殿的任何地方，挤在一起，汗流浃背，
bloodstained, hungry, wet. It's a classic science fiction thing, isn't it? Yeah. You're stuck in the spaceship. Yeah. You've run out of ammunition. It's the plot of Aliens or something. Yes. The aliens are outside and they're all waiting to come and lay their eggs in your stomach. It is. I mean, Bernal Diaz says, we were to be sacrificed to their gods. Our hearts were to be torn from our bodies. The blood was to be drawn from our veins, and our arms and legs were to be eaten at their festivals. Our other body parts would be thrown to the tigers, lions, and serpents, which hadn't been fed for days, so they would devour our flesh with real enthusiasm. I mean, this is obviously pure projection. He doesn't know any of this.
血迹斑斑，饥肠辘辘，潮湿。这是一个经典的科幻情节，不是吗？是的。你被困在宇宙飞船里。是的。你的弹药用完了。这是《异形》（Aliens）之类的剧情。是的。外星人在外面，他们都在等着进来把卵产在你的胃里。确实是。我的意思是，贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯说：“我们要被献祭给他们的神。我们的心脏要从身体里被挖出来。血液要从我们的静脉中抽出，我们的手臂和腿要在他们的节日里被吃掉。我们身体的其他部分会被扔给老虎、狮子和蛇，它们已经好几天没吃东西了，所以它们会带着真正的热情吞噬我们的肉。”我的意思是，这显然是纯粹的投射。他根本不知道这些。
Well, there are no tigers or lions, are there? You already pointed this out. But this is probably exactly what they're thinking. Of course. That nothing good is coming. There are stories that they start seeing omens, headless men. One man says he'd seen a head walking around outside attached only to a foot. Imagine that with kind of hopping. Yeah, exactly.
好吧，没有老虎或狮子，不是吗？你已经指出了这一点。但这很可能正是他们所想的。当然。没有什么好事会发生。有故事说他们开始看到预兆，无头的人。一个人说他看到一个头在外面走动，只连着一只脚。想象一下那种跳跃的样子。是的，完全正确。
That probably didn't happen to him, I think. That's the kind of thing you take if you go into the depths of Mexico and take certain substances. Exactly. That's what you'd see. At some point, obviously, Cortés decides, okay, we're in desperation now. We'll bring Montezuma out. We'll give it one more go. And they take him out onto the roof again.
我想那可能没有发生在他身上。如果你深入墨西哥并服用某些物质，你就会看到那种东西。完全正确。那就是你会看到的。在某个时刻，显然，科尔特斯决定，好吧，我们现在处于绝望之中。我们会把蒙特祖马带出来。我们会再试一次。他们又把他带到了屋顶上。
And this is this very, very, very famous scene. There are people throwing stones, arrows all this whenever they see a spaniard so as soon as cortez goes out onto the roof this hail of missiles some of the spaniards use their shields to protect montezuma and they bring him out and when the crowd sees the emperor they stop and there's this sort of hush and montezuma god knows how is he imposing is he exhausted and terrified is he in in despair? Is he begging? But he says to them, hear me, people of the Mexica or something like this. And then, as if it's a signal, though probably it wasn't a signal, but as if it's a signal,
这是这个非常、非常、非常著名的场景。每当人们看到西班牙人时，就会有人扔石头、射箭，所以当科尔特斯一走到屋顶上，这阵导弹雨，一些西班牙人用他们的盾牌保护蒙特祖马，他们把他带了出来，当人群看到皇帝时，他们停了下来，有一种安静，蒙特祖马，天知道他是怎么想的，他是威严的，还是精疲力竭和恐惧的，他是在绝望中吗？他在乞求吗？但他对他们说：“听我说，墨西加的人民……”或者类似的话。然后，就像这是一个信号，虽然可能不是信号，但就像这是一个信号，
the crowd start throwing more stuff at him. They just drown him out with jeers. And as one Spaniard says, it was as if the heavens were raining stones, arrows, darts, and bricks. And Montezuma is hit by a stone. Or is he? Well, I think it's plausible that he could be hit. The Spaniards claim he's hit. This feels like it could happen. It could easily happen that the people down below are hotheads. There may well be people in the crowd saying, he sold us out to the strangers from the sea.
人群开始向他扔更多的东西。他们只是用嘲笑声淹没了他。正如一位西班牙人所说，就好像天空在下石头、箭、飞镖和砖块。蒙特祖马被一块石头击中了。还是他被击中了？好吧，我认为他可能被击中是可信的。西班牙人声称他被击中了。这感觉像是可能发生的。这很容易发生，下面的人是冲动的人。人群中很可能有人说：“他把我们卖给了来自大海的陌生人。”
So Matthew Restle in his book suggests there are five theories as to how he might have died. So projectiles and it's manslaughter, or that the people down there are deliberately trying to kill Moctezuma, in which case it's murder. That Moctezuma kind of kills himself, that he's deliberately exposing himself because he's in despair. The fourth one is that Cuauhtemoc, who we haven't mentioned yet, who is kind of the hot-headed relative who is keen to succeed him, that he's responsible. And then the fifth is that the Spaniards kill him, that they're stabbed to death. So there's an odd detail in one of the accounts written by a Jesuit who says that there were those who said that in order for the wound, i.e. the stab, not to be seen, they put a sword into his nether regions.
所以马修·雷斯特尔（Matthew Restle）在他的书中提出了关于他可能如何死亡的五种理论。所以是投射物，那是过失杀人，或者下面的人是故意要杀死蒙特祖马，在这种情况下是谋杀。蒙特祖马某种程度上自杀了，他故意暴露自己，因为他陷入了绝望。第四个是库奥特莫克（Cuauhtemoc），我们还没提到他，他是那个急于继位的冲动亲戚，他对此负责。然后第五个是西班牙人杀了他，他是被刺死的。所以在一个由耶稣会士写的记载中有一个奇怪的细节，他说有人说为了不让伤口，即刺伤，被看到，他们把一把剑插进了他的下体。
Yes. In other words, the Spanish stab him up his ass. It's so Tom Holland to go for the nether regions story. And there's another weird story that his body gets kind of lifted up. His sword's been run up through his ass and they're kind of lifting him up on the sword and waving him around on the roof, which seems very improbable. I think that's very improbable. Yes. So I'll give you my accounts in just a second, but here is the absolute standard accounts
是的。换句话说，西班牙人从他的屁股后面刺了他。汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）去讲下体的故事真是太典型了。还有一个奇怪的故事说他的尸体被抬了起来。他的剑从屁股后面穿过，他们把他抬在剑上，在屋顶上挥舞，这看起来非常不可信。我认为那非常不可信。是的。所以我马上会给你我的记载，但这是绝对标准的记载
from Bernal Diaz. Bernal Diaz says he was hit by these missiles on the roof. The Spaniards took him downstairs. They bandaged his wounds and they asked him to take something that would strengthen him, but he refused as though he'd lost the will to live. Bernard Diaz says, contrary to all expectation, we soon heard that he had expired. Cortes, his officers and all of us shed tears for this unfortunate monarch. Indeed, many of our men who had been in constant attendance upon him mourned for him as if they had lost a parent. Right. So throughout this series and just recently, you've been comparing
来自贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯。贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯说他在屋顶上被这些导弹击中了。西班牙人把他带到楼下。他们包扎了他的伤口，并要求他吃点能增强体力的东西，但他拒绝了，好像他失去了活下去的意志。贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯说：“出乎所有人的意料，我们很快听说他已经去世了。科尔特斯、他的军官和我们所有人都为这位不幸的君主落泪。事实上，我们许多一直侍奉他的人为他哀悼，就像失去了亲人一样。”好吧。所以在这个系列中，就在最近，你一直在比较
Cortes and the Spaniards to Caesar and his legions. And the scene of Caesar weeping over the death of Pompey, his rival and his friend, this is the kind of the language that you would expect from a classically educated historian who is trying to elevate the stature of Cortes, which man who has proved himself so cold-blooded, ruthless and opportunistic, standing there with tears rolling down his cheeks at the death of his great friend. I mean, against that, the Spanish have killed a lot of kings before. I mean, then Queens, they killed Queen on Hispaniola. They've killed Hachuey in Cuba. I mean, they're not exactly reticent about it. But don't forget it's important to them to claim that he had surrendered to them. Yeah. He can't be their enemy. Yeah. So that's the explanation, isn't it? I think.
科尔特斯和西班牙人与凯撒和他的军团。凯撒为他的对手和朋友庞培（Pompey）的死而哭泣的场景，这是你期望从一个受过古典教育的历史学家那里听到的语言，他试图提升科尔特斯的地位，这个被证明如此冷酷、无情和机会主义的人，站在那里，在伟大的朋友去世时泪流满面。我的意思是，相比之下，西班牙人以前杀过很多国王。我的意思是，然后是女王，他们在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛（Hispaniola）杀死了女王。他们在古巴杀死了哈图伊（Hachuey）。我的意思是，他们对此并不怎么避讳。但别忘了，声称他已经向他们投降对他们来说很重要。是的。他不能是他们的敌人。是的。所以这就是解释，不是吗？我想。
Now there is a hint in an indigenous source of a very different version. This is a book called The History of the Indies of New Spain, which was published in 1581 by a guy called Diego Duran, who was a Dominican. He is not obviously indigenous, but he based it on Nahuatl sources. So it's not just indigenous. It has a hint of Spanish in it as well. He says that after the Spanish had left Tenochtitlan, which we'll come to tomorrow, the Mexica burst into the building. They found Montezuma with a chain about his feet and five dagger wounds in his chest.
现在，在一个土著来源中有一个非常不同版本的暗示。这是一本名为《新西班牙印第安人历史》（The History of the Indies of New Spain）的书，由一个叫迭戈·杜兰（Diego Duran）的多米尼加人在1581年出版。他显然不是土著，但他基于纳瓦特尔语（Nahuatl）的来源。所以它不仅仅是土著的。它也有一点西班牙的成分。他说，在西班牙人离开特诺奇蒂特兰之后，我们明天会讲到，墨西加人冲进了大楼。他们发现蒙特祖马脚上带着链子，胸口有五处刀伤。
And nearby lay the nobles and great lords that had been held prisoner with him. And you mentioned the Jesuit source that say that the Spaniards shoved the sword in his nether regions. I think the nether regions thing to me smacks too much of what happens to kings. You know, Edward II, all these kinds of things, that it's too much of a standard device. But is it plausible that they would have had him chained and that they would have stabbed him in the chest?
附近躺着与他一起被囚禁的贵族和大领主。你提到了耶稣会士的来源，说西班牙人把剑插进了他的下体。我认为下体的事情对我来说太像国王身上发生的事情了。你知道，爱德华二世（Edward II），所有这些事情，这太像是一种标准的手段了。但他们把他锁起来，并刺伤他的胸口是可信的吗？
I think absolutely it is because he clearly is no longer useful to them. If his own people won't listen to him, what is the point? What is the point of keeping him alive? He's just a focus for rebellion and resistance because we know they killed other people, his advisors and other nobles. It's also a very brutally decisive statement of the resolution that Cortez presumably by this point has taken, which is they have no choice but to get out. Negotiations are not going to work. And in a way, it's kind of, again, a crossing of the Rubicon. If you kill your hostage, then that leaves you with no option but to try and make your escape. And that, Dominic, is the story for tomorrow.
我认为绝对是，因为他显然对他来说不再有用了。如果他自己的人民不听他的，那有什么意义？让他活着有什么意义？他只是叛乱和抵抗的焦点，因为我们知道他们杀了其他人，他的顾问和其他贵族。这也是一个非常残酷果断的声明，关于科尔特斯此时大概已经做出的决定，那就是他们别无选择，只能离开。谈判不会奏效。在某种程度上，这又是一种跨越卢比孔河（Rubicon）的行为。如果你杀了你的人质，那么你就别无选择，只能尝试逃跑。而那，多米尼克，就是明天的故事。
It is. So I think exactly that, Tom. I think they've killed Montezuma because they don't want to take him with them. Because at this point, they have decided somehow, Tom, they have to get out of this city. And the story of how they do it is the most extraordinary kind of... It's like something from an action movie times a hundred. The Noce Triste, it's called, isn't it? The sad night. Yeah. We'll come to that tomorrow.
确实是。所以我认为正是这样，汤姆。我认为他们杀了蒙特祖马，因为他们不想带他走。因为在这一点上，他们已经决定了，某种程度上，汤姆，他们必须离开这座城市。而他们如何做到的故事是最非凡的……就像动作电影乘以一百。这被称为“悲伤之夜”（Noce Triste），不是吗？悲伤的夜晚。是的。我们明天会讲到那个。
Yes. So that will be tomorrow's episode. But if you just can't wait, you know the form. I've been repeating this at the end of every episode, but I'm contractually obliged to do this because if I don't, Theo will shout at me. So you can find out if the Spaniards make their escape, if they do, how they do it, by signing up to the Restless History Club
是的。所以那将是明天的剧集。但如果你等不及了，你知道形式。我在每一集的结尾都在重复这一点，但我有合同义务这样做，因为如果我不这样做，西奥（Theo）会对我大喊大叫。所以你可以通过注册“其余的历史俱乐部”（Restless History Club）来了解西班牙人是否成功逃脱，如果他们成功了，他们是如何做到的。
and you will get access to it straight away. But if you want to wait, then do by all means wait. Yeah, what you've done there, which is very nice, is you've cast yourself as Montezuma, Theo as Hernan Cortes, and that makes me Pedro de Alvarado. So I'm going to be keeping my legs crossed before we get on to the next episode. Very nice.
你将立即获得访问权限。但如果你想等，那就一定要等。是的，你刚才做的事情，非常好，你把自己塑造成了蒙特祖马，西奥是埃尔南·科尔特斯（Hernan Cortes），这让我成了佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多。所以在我进入下一集之前，我会把腿交叉起来。非常好。
So we'll see you either in a few minutes or tomorrow. Hasta luego. Bye bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
所以我们会在几分钟后或明天见到你。Hasta luego（再见）。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们一起主持《其余的是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周的
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。